hey guys this is a tutorial on how to
get the new tab button into mozilla
firefox uh just like that of internet
explorer first of all i'll show you that
in internet explorer here it is right
here
um anytime you click it you'll get a
brand new tab in the background and
it'll say you've opened a new tab so
i'll exit internet explorer
and in firefox all you have to do to do
this first open a search engine and type
type
firefox add-ons make sure you're doing
this in firefox it makes it easier click
on firefox add-ons the first very first
link add-ons.mozilla.org
and you're going to search for add-ons
and we're going to search
new tab
button
in new tab button the third one
will say
new tab button position and it'll look
just like this this is exactly what we
want we're going to hit the add to
firefox button
and install now
restart firefox
and as it comes back we have a new tab
button
there it is at any time we can open a
new blank tab
as well as
close a blank tab
if we go to tools and add-ons
we also have a number of settings that
we can change hit options
and say do you want it to be at the left
side of the tab bar the right side of
the last tab bar or at the right end
which is way over here
i just like it at the right side of the
last tab
which is right here
that's basically it new tab new tablet
position 0.6.0
um
you can find updates at any time there
are no updates for this so
this is the newest version
i'm going to use it a lot more you know
just
surfing the web
i need tabs firefox you have to go to
file a new tab every time you want a new
tab
i'd rather just hit one button it's that
much faster guys so
if you like this video
subscribe to my channel
peace out